you
okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are talking about
experimental features and more from
language which might become an
experimental in the future
so first up machine learning
okay
all right let's take a look at okay
there's a lot of stuff here not very
well grouped
so the anomaly detection stuff why do
you want to keep that okay it's
something that I've introduced in 12 and
we are changing a little bit the design
[Music]
yes so there is just one point about
most of these functions that you see on
top learn distribution especially
derivatives of learn distribution that
are anomaly detection find anomalies and
synthesize missing values so this has
been recently introducing 12 so I think
that it would be a good idea to keep
them experimental for another round and
then making debug and let user see where
the flaws are because I'm why do we
think learn distribution is exempt from
us why do we think learn distribution is
it's um so yeah I ya know I kind of
disagree with with amia I don't think
it's because we just introduced them
that it should be kept experimental yeah
learn distribution as a good design I
don't think will change the design I'm
convinced a good design like it we have
exactly like the other distribution is
his term in terms of you know run a
brigade PDF and so on I think it
straightforward in terms of design in
terms of integration to the system there
are still a few things we can do and I
think we're going to do them for this
version for example probability and
expectation I've been working with go
SIA for calf technical distribution and
it's the same problem so I think we'll
there will never be a perfect
integration on you already
let's say you used I've learned
distribution with all the distribution
in the system let's say if all
distributions yeah like if you use
product distribution or mixture
distribution but I think it's already
the case between this version of the
product like if you use a quantity
distribution you cannot mix it with
let's say non quantity distribution so I
think it's neural integration will be
quite similar to what the integration of
let's say
means random variate for example
certainly works at some level on the
distribution although it's not terribly
impressive
wait why random variate yeah
what are you [ __ ] well here so I used to
appoint one I'll use 12.1 double this
okay so let's say I do I do learn
distribution let me let me get a bunch
of pictures of dogs or something no okay
okay yes it's not very good talk about
images we need to figure out how to do
the transfer learning for image so it's
a separate it's okay so what does it
work for actually okay okay okay no
that's I mean yeah numeric value of
course yeah there's another restriction
is that in this version I mean currently
still cannot handle sequences so what
kind of text or let's say time series
but anything of fixed dimension it's
gonna work on I think it works pretty
well yeah the image the special case we
have to figure out how to do the
transfer learning and that's that's a
project we have currently alright okay
so anomaly detection so what's changing
with anomaly detection so in we want to
have the possibility to train your learn
distribution and then create anomaly
detector or directly find memories or
delete anomalies with this distribution
but currently they don't you know
there's no way to like if you use
synthesizing values you can use it in
two ways either directly on data and it
satisfies the missing values or in two
steps where you first train the
distribution and then use synthesize
missing value on the distribution and
but here you can use this anomaly
detector function yes yes here we learn
distribution instead of the analytical
function and same thing for it anomaly
is any animal detector sorry in animal a
detection you should be able to yeah
just give it to learn distribute get a
spirit ll receive Shia to define and it
will transform animated a function so I
don't think it
wait-wait-wait-wait you're just saying a
first argument to anomaly detection that
is a learned distribution which is
essentially the distribution with
respect to which you're asking for an
always is that correct yes and there's
no second argument like it's just a real
pleasure example is just to convert a
distribution into an anomaly detector
and yeah and you can also use directly
in find anomalies and in delete
anomalies user learned distribution okay
I'm actually yeah I'm I mean don't you
already have that technology to go from
learn distribution learned distribution
to what's the difference yes what is the
difference between an anomaly detector
function okay they don't only detect a
function you can specific it does that
give true or false yes yes it gives
strong false yes to a fault and your
properties your properties of
probability but normally it's a true or
false yes yeah it's yeah it's trivial
for us to do the Chandra it's just so
they design make the change
yeah we are we are as we're making I
would be I'll be okay to take
experimental eyes that I mean I would
have thought so I can't see any reason
they don't seem expert they don't okay
there's one thing is that since its
reasons it's true that we are kind of
fine-tuning some heuristics like finding
that new box and stuff and like users
use it like recently and in general
anomalies are a little bit vague what
are their definitions or for users to do
so you're saying the answers are gonna
change yes but one knows that for any
machine learning function yeah I mean if
we said the answers will never change
will never be you know we'd never be
able to do expertise anything even image
identify or anything like that no that's
true I think I think yeah design wise
this is change we're gonna we're going
to be fine and how much is it gonna
change do we know I mean as we change it
we might change a little bit more but as
we also trying to integrate it with
other things
no but I'm talking about changing the
design I'm not talking about changing
the design
I don't think should change merch we
just add this adding the land
distribution there's one thing though
that we might maybe give a method or
something because you know that is
chicken and egg problem when you want to
find
I don't melis you wanna train something
doesn't happen Amelie exactly exactly
it's like the classic you know chicken
and egg and and for this which is the
dominant nevermind I not going sorry
so we might give the user the facility -
two - two - oh wait yes yes yes that's
another thing that's another thing we
forgot about it yes that's another yeah
the design difference that we might
implement it depends in how oh wait a
second this is to give a set of examples
that are not anomalies yes exactly as
you're saying here a bunch of examples
that are in a sense implicitly not
anomalous Miss Ellie no nice Ellie no no
no no is that example is we assumption
is there's a few anomalies in it ask a
user to label those ones so they would
help us to learn the distribution only
on the non-anomalous form and tune the
acceptance threshold based on that
normal data at labelled anomalies
that's another we might want to all
right fine but I mean so that's are
there gonna be an association their
positions release of example and then a
rule and then you know position one five
and I would do true false I would do
anomaly detection example two false
no no because this is gonna be I mean
anomalies are very rare by default by
definition yeah it's gonna be it's gonna
be false everywhere and just true in
like you know one percent of the case so
I don't think that's all right then I
don't think that that I don't agree with
your syntax I mean another
you know I would prefer to have
something where you break that into an
association which says normal and
anomalous and you just have a bucket of
normal examples in a book yeah I mean
yeah would allow I guess every syntax of
classify allows but the one that we kind
of my mystery to me yeah this doesn't
seem like a reason to not be
experimental eyes this this clear you
can add some tax to deal with this yeah
yeah yeah no no I agree it's not
backward-compatible all right so that
that means that what we're talking about
is anomaly detection and I believe
detect a function I don't know what
computer uncertainty is that's not
really related this is a option to
specify letting classify our
measurements okay so that's a general
option I don't know we have Roger on
this call but I mean that's a general
option that I can imagine using in many
functions that basically returns around
numbers
right that's not yet supported in many
places but there's no good reason why
that can't be supported in lots of
places so I mean that's a LCC question
to figure out where that could what
could be supported okay I I would agree
to leave it yeah we should leave it
experimental here because we don't know
how it's gonna get supported elsewhere
now that's what I thought too
this is a huge mess I mean this is this
is I mean in general synthesized missing
value kinda related to these
unsupervised learning functions I think
we should if you want to keep the other
ones that like make the other one the
experimental eyes I think synthesized
missing values since we don't have a
good way to annotating machines like in
images in different type of data right
now I think at least synthesized missing
values and missing value pattern needs
to stay experimental well okay so wait a
minute wait a minute we just worked on
annotation for images right so do you
guys know what the I mean this whole
annotation rules and all is gonna stuff
have you guys looked at that that's a
pretty good framework for annotating
everything and the question of whether
how it annotates so I mean I think we're
supposed to have some summit meeting
about missing right and so this needs to
be I don't know who's who is I don't
know whose p.m. in here but um um this
missing value pattern needs to be
brought up in that whole discussion
about missing and arithmetic on missings
and so on yes yeah I can make note of it
okay and can we get some time next few
weeks than the missing summit organized
please yes okay so I agree with you
let's leave miss synthesize missing
values experimental until we've done
that yes yes we need to figure out that
and then after that people very publicly
I don't have a problem to experimental I
think I think it's kind of a cool
concept about that by the way yes so we
have this ordering function that we need
to add and actually I realize that
actually the useful function is not
probability is this radical type you
know probability I realized working with
categorical distribution that you don't
really like for detecting anomalies you
don't care about let's say you have a
uniform distribution okay if you ask
where a probability of anything of this
uniform distribution can recall uniform
this region actually would work for
continuous anyway it's going to be zero
which mean that it's it's it's anomaly
which is of course not an anomaly for
any of them because it's really for us a
rarer should be defined as well or equal
yes actually yeah I mean in practice
that's what you want well so let's just
define it that way I mean we it hasn't
mattered for continuous distributions by
epsilon but why not change its
definition so that for categorical
distributions it actually works we could
yeah and then the name is a little bit
misleading because it's not pretty rare
error but recall I mean I guess you
could argue
we spent a long time figuring out this
name I think it's a great name
I think it's a great name rare property
it's just very clear and short well and
for continuous distributions there is no
difference between where equal or error
so the issue is only with karakov
categorical distributions correct
actually sorry I think I said something
stupid Stephen
the always uniform and Caracol
we're a probability I'm getting confused
now I think it's fine I don't think we
have a problem
well why don't you guys think about it
yeah sure we can move on if there isn't
a problem actually there is a problem
yes all right sorry back in subscriber
problem yes a problem is the uniform
distribution right the probability to be
rarer is actually zero yes and
in that it is an anomaly because it's a
that's how do you find O'Malley that
nothing can be more extreme than that
so it's think that it's an extreme event
I mean when use case is the technical
knowledge right that's its use case over
our probability and the way it works is
that when you have a small probability
I mean there's nothing that is rarer
which would mean it's an event that is
extreme
so very common event that will have a
reprimand on the standard formal
distribution it's going to be it's the
probability is is whatever it is you
know point five or 0.1 or something it's
always point one there's nothing rarer
than it exactly so it means it is
extreme which actually is not true
so but if you do we're equal then it all
works fine okay so the probability for
distribution to generate a sample that
has a
well I mean that would have to be
changed to lower or equal PDF that's
exactly ample exactly exactly
and it has been pointed out by things
Chandler and that that focus I recall we
needed was equal as well for then we
thought oh let's put an option like an
ordering function option no that's good
yeah but since the true word probably
will never really be useful maybe we
yeah we just do is a very cool I mean we
still call it for a primitive but in
truth it does let me just think about
that for a second rarer that would be my
turn to just say it's rare or equal and
this is kind of a corner case I mean if
you're looking at the CDF for example
okay what's for a uniform distribution
what is the CDF for uniform continues
dimensional but it's to line its
line that jumps no no no up I go from
zero like her like it goes from zero to
PDF so but on the other hand what is the
but it's
we shouldn't rethink of CDF for our
ability thing is confusing what is the
mathematical computation of a given a
probability P of X if you open detailing
options so we they'll be the it's
actually like mathematically this
so it's the probability of X that we are
interested right long as the p-value
work for for categorical distributions
I don't think is defined it's not
defined
p-value is really for you know
uni-dimensional
numerical dis numeric distribution
that of ya only one mode yeah entails
and that's the very restrict this is
very restrictive to one dimension
symmetric distribution I am I'm a word
right but but no definitely not for
categorical distribution like it's not
that said to true definition of this
event extrema not it is example extrema
not well my provisional thought would be
make this rarer or equal okay
I mean it changes does not have a higher
PDF than example Julia reality I think
it's gonna be good that's what we want
anyway so fine alright but I think we
should plan to do experimental eyes the
thing because okay okay
features space plot 3d I cannot believe
that that is not the experimental eyes
of all what does it sis you there is
this legend it thing otherwise and
legend thing is something that you can
do in 3d can you do legend ding in
general in 3d right now
I mean you know this it was this idea
that if you have labels data that have
only few labels then there would be
something going on and we haven't
figured that out but obviously minor
change of design so I'll pick it will
change the design I change the outlet
slightly at least not not
backward-compatible right I think we
should be experimental eyes this unless
there's some other issue which I'm not
aware of cause I mean I've certainly
used this plenty we should we should
have asked bread right here I don't have
a strong opinion whether I should be up
okay all right fine textual answer that
is a can of worms
I film you some people would be
disappointed so to what to make okay at
all is where is that yeah right it
doesn't work perfectly because it's a
really hard problem yeah yeah I think we
leave it as experimental there also in
terms of design currently just select
the question which has maybe in the
future it will just formulate and on so
we select the answer maybe in the future
it will formulate a new answer I see but
beside that well I think also this is
the place where what we really want is
the enhancement to text cases that shows
you know entities and quantities and all
that kind of thing because I mean really
really what we want here is much more
you know with the how much does the
rhinoceros way is
yeah something much more structured like
you know forces yes yes yes exactly
exactly yeah doesn't do currently so I
think experimental is a writer also for
designer kind of a kind of a fine
textual answer meets text cases with
interpretation by the way are we
changing the default for text cases to
give interpretation no and I'm not sure
we should for practical reason well the
fact that it's slower does you know at
least shows you what it's doing it's
true that now we have the Box the money
talking I tell you that it interprets
and so on I don't think that's I mean
anyway okay with Brett we're talking
about features based plot 3d and we
can't understand whether there's a
graphics visualisation reason why it
should still be experimental I think it
should stay experimental until we sort
out the multi case what multi case well
so identifying yeah so if you have say a
whole bunch of data on the president's
you know you know how you split them
into their respective political parties
and style them accordingly or whatever
which is you know tied into what attends
comment in the notebook is there about
legend yeah but we haven't made any
features place block it's not
experimental I thought it still was yes
yes here's a mother oh well then why the
heck oh yeah listing one of them it's
listed I guess further don't really look
next to each other yeah I guess it's
because right there the soul team we can
even make three before I thought I saw
it I saw it according to the version it
was
to usun and features place plot 2d
gaming Levantine okay okay okay well
that's an issue because this is a major
widely used function so it should not be
staying experimental what Rison
experimental now because you say you
would like to be able to tag things what
good is it to tag them because we've
already got display for these objects
don't we I see what you're saying you
you say we could have something where
you label the the object red or blue or
something like that and then you show
where in feature space those things lie
and you see how many outliers they are
and you see whether there's some tooltip
of that's the person who you know voted
this way for everything but is nominally
that or something something like that
yes okay which the classic classic
example I mean yeah right
just sitting okay so the issue is to
give an overlay of a style for these
examples so for example putting arrow
whatever in those examples correct
correct
yeah well that would be a good thing to
do and I think you know the spatial
statistics team is going to have similar
sorts of requirements and so I expect
those will inform each other a bit on
how the visualization design works and
whatnot
mm-hmm well when will that be known I
don't think
getting it for 12 one but it's what
they're working on so I would assume the
version after that okay well can we can
we find out can we build preliminary
discussion about this design with them
find out whether they already know the
design that they could want to use right
Roger and I have discussed it some and I
think arrows is going to be listen you
know the syntax so let's see if we can
let down so that we can do experimental
eyes features based plot which is a
widely used function and really
shouldn't be experimental right every
saw some feature space plot right now
with arrows uses labels I think set
right that's in do you remember with
arrows right so if you have a list of
rules it doesn't document I mean it's
not doctored I don't think it does
anything I mean I know
okay so
say I mean don't use an image cuz that's
gonna be confusing why okay that won't
be confusing well if it is or isn't
we'll find out
where are the forces
more wrong I mean I would expect that
behavior if it was none instead of false
well what what is the right hand side
mean it's treating it as a label but
none is a special label it's the don't
show the two strings anything label well
if prime Q right it's just just a two
string of prime Q
okay okay looks pretty good to me in
which case they can probably be unfused
and yeah yeah it'll just be additional
processing on the right hand sides yeah
looks good to me
I didn't even know that worked would we
want there to have a legend because I
kind of I mean I don't think the legend
is useful in that case you would still
see the I mean there's two things we
could do right right you would see when
the classes are but you mean they
wouldn't identify in any way
well the question whether we tooltip'
each individual thing I mean this is
giving the label but we can still
tooltip it to say more detail about what
it is and we should be doing that so
listen
it needs a small amount of work and it
needs to actually document this label
behavior which I had no idea existed
right and then we should be able to do
experimental eyes it along with it and I
mean I think the legend is super useful
because yes so just a repetition of I
mean you have a B which are small but
when you have big tags you know you Java
applet tags
whereas if you just have like don't
different colors and in the legend of
the tags I mean that's how you would do
it right if you want to show that I just
take auto election I like that idea of
instead of saying all the A's and B's
you would see red and blue or something
then there would be a legend that well
so you have an option that decides
whether that's happening or not right
all right so there's a small amount of
design why don't you work on that and
bring it back to some other meeting okay
okay preserve color and I think
that's it for me rights oh don't count
on it hold on yes that's it for you okay
see you later see you right
that is a very weird option
I wonder whether it's usable in other
places
who knows
um
she probably didn't like it a method or
something well I think it's a big deal
whether you preserve color or not I
don't know what's happening to me trees
tell them whether how much it's evolving
do you know I don't think anything
happened since we released it
we had a wonderful doing yeah we had the
idea of doing more building image
cristyne like eating styles basically
yes wonders
that's not been done you know just too
bad because I think diet let me add that
to a list of projects for something here
[Music]
but typically when as a network that is
trained for this one style he's gonna
perform better than our network that can
work for any style on the spot right can
also be made I think small and it's fine
okay um well I don't know what to do
with that option by the way some
background noise some people's put
themselves on mute
I don't think leaving is experimental is
terribly useful
I suggest we do experimental eyes that
the function itself is to experimental
eyes I don't really see any reason to
leave that experimental it is what it is
whether we can use it in other functions
I don't know
okay
okay
you
yeah this is a WL my life we don't know
what to do with it
okay the active star functions yep
not super used they're not no
disappointing which
there may be two to reason I mean I
can't agree went three way to go forward
maybe this is a correct design and and
it's just not misused because you know
octave classification is not something
super used which I'm not sure it's okay
I think us look it's so much more
complicated than classify yes yes it's
much yeah the fact that you have this
function you have to put it's more
complicated you kind of have to have a
robot probing the real world or
something I mean it it's some yes yes
yes yes yes I think people are not used
to doing this yet
training example the one thing but yes
and often the hard part is praying the
function let's say you do active
classification for images where it's you
know turkle's that tagged the image yeah
so our part is only the function like
the activation grasper doesn't bring
much value but it's like okay well I
could do it myself so I mean we should
think about it but there may be one
design where the function is actually
not inside the function if I may the F
is not inside the function where it's
just you have an object you know that at
the state yeah and you can of them you
know it gives you configuration to tag
and then you add this configuration to
the object and then he tells you which
one to tag next and but there's no the
function there so
so it's a bit lower level in the sense
that look I don't think I think we
should you know this design will become
clearer when we have Gans working and so
on
and can't I'm not well
but reinforcement learning yeah
reinforcement learning thing which was
kind of one of the goal of this project
actually I know that push ourselves must
be learning and and windows to things
like how to represent space you know
with the sampler let's say
[Music]
I think we yeah this brought us that I
think well we should leave these
experimental for the time being until we
have reinforcement learning working and
we have the same problem with Bayesian
stuff the exact same very similar story
whereas in maximization yes it's also a
function is inside the function and
sorry I'm the sequence predicted thing
I'm hoping that's gonna be much better
yes so this is currently work on so we
have our live stream ethan saying i have
absolutely no idea how to use actually
classification and i have a PhD in
machine learning i think it's the worst
function in Mathematica okay oh wow
there's actually one cool example that I
did in the product page where you have
to code and you want to find which one
is faster
the this was actually useful anyway what
was that for that was for that was for
deciding for automated f2 code and has
the exact same stuff yeah
so you want to train a classifier that
predicts should we use code a or code B
that's a good use case yeah and this one
was a good use case
yeah um so yes how again coming along do
we have a something to say about that
yeah it's gonna be there in the next
version and exclusive I'm going to
present something at a tech conference
about it but basically with minimal
design change now you can still use net
train still have everything as if you
were training a normal network but this
time it's gonna be again that's good
because we didn't think it was possible
to keep the same design and Afghan but
actually it and the tricks to have this
learning rate multipliers that can be
set to minus one into negative and and
this training update schedule I think
it's gonna be called let's say you can
train this part of the network and then
this part three times and this part one
part you know one time thing like that
and with that you can do get
right I mean honestly that your example
helps me understand why I think active
classification or active prediction is
not totally crazy I mean even the design
doesn't seem crazy to me I just think
that it's one of these things that you
have to believe in machine learning even
more than for some of this other stuff
to think that it's going to do something
reasonable because if it just starts
poking away at some part of the space
that's irrelevant yeah yeah that's why
the version that were more step-by-step
and just tell you what to do next would
be bit more you know and understandable
for the user and where you're explicitly
having to where it tells you go sample
this value yes yes how you return that
although you won't be able to do the
program example right before with this
design or at least one way there's this
way to do that currently like you know
your active classification object and
you can grab the value inside so there's
a way to use active in a step-by-step
way and always knowing what's what you
know which value is being sample and so
on
same for buyers in unionization but it's
a bit of a clunky way like so the main
way to use it is with a black box
function and just think I was in the
background
and now I believe that is the actual
main way that people diversification is
more the step by step over word not sure
yes
Baban our livestream is asking whether
this will work with new video functions
but he doesn't understand what active
classification actually does necessarily
look the point guys is it's simply for
classify you pre generate a bunch of
training examples for active
classification it's deciding what new
training example to generate based on
what it's already seen
you
you
and that's not a crazy thing to do I
mean that's a you know
well look the example of those
yeah I mean the the example of the witch
thing is faster after all eventually
it's trying to learn it for some space
of possible input problems and if it
does not successfully probe that space
then you're just gonna get stupid
answers right I mean if it if it says
well I did a really good job figuring
out over in this corner here what's
going to happen but then you present it
with an example in real life that's over
at the opposite corner and it says well
I'm sorry I never I never classify you
know I never learnt on that so you're in
luck
right that's the type of thing that
could go wrong here yeah it's called
reverse to that though because it always
has a mixture of sampling from you know
the sample you gave or uniform from the
region you gave and the more fine-grain
so it's quite quite robust for this sort
of stuff
like it's not gonna get fooled
actually usually your ma disappointing
on the other way you look at where dozen
sample you said oh why don't you do more
sample in this area you know that seems
to be more confused because it's a
little bit cautious and we spend some
time making sure that that it's that it
had a fit strategy depending on the
speed of the function yeah
right first people are suggesting that
better intend examples here will be
useful yeah this is an unexplored area I
mean this whole act of classification
thing has not gotten as much development
as not development actually as much some
exposure as we might like um listen we
are over time for this meeting and we
have another one coming right up
although we need about a five minute
break here um and
somebody's talking about
action techniques which I thought we had
rather good rather good versions of um
wrap up here next time we'll talk about
the feature extraction functions which
have a lot of complexity here boy
there's a lot of stuff - um
when we do streams we we we do them when
we have relevant meetings and today this
afternoon for example we have one coming
up in five or ten minutes and then
another one later on this afternoon
about geometry and graphics at 4:00 p.m.
eastern US time um all right we should
we should wrap up this meeting and for
those following livestream we'll move it
back again and five or ten minutes right
talk to you all soon
tea Thanks